first before we do the questions to talk
about the past us oh yeah UFC 207 Ronda
Rousey Amanda Nunez incredible
absolutely incredible
Ronda and I'm gonna this is what in my
opinion I bought it is okay it was
telling my brother this is is that you
know my brother and I have been fans at
the USC since the beginning I mean we
were in a prime we're in the prize but
even before that you would see guys like
Coleman or conker remember car of the
wrestler Igor Vovchanchyn
yeah and even like tank Abbott right so
they were great yes fun for their time
but I take Abbott can't beat a John
Jones home right and because because the
the sport evolved yeah and you got when
you have more money and more eyes
watching it and as when it becomes more
legitimate you get more legitimate
athletes wanting to participate and now
you have excellent athletes the greatest
in the world competing in men's UFC I
think that Ronda Rousey was good for her
time yeah pioneer pioneer but there
wasn't a lot of people in that time
great doing it yeah they're hard there
hadn't been a lot of girls who were
either muy Thai girls or girls who had
decided okay let's try MMA because it's
a lucrative career for us it just wasn't
an option then because it really wasn't
a lucrative career so Ronda Rousey
didn't have the pool of women to
actually to truly compete with I did
there were if you're not you can't
discount the fact that you know she did
be cat Zingano you should be yeah she's
beat me should say she's she definitely
fought some strong girls but it's still
very limited pool of of women yeah she
fought but if you see the dismantling of
Misha Misha Tate versus Amanda Newhall
dude she destroyed don't ask you
something okay
if I'm Ronda Rousey's met coach he's
dumb who ed much Yeah right
I'm a versed and we're you watch the
Miesha Tate fight while you would have
to like show Rhonda this is Amanda you
fighting Misha we
you'd then encourage her to do striking
with her no Amanda Nunez isn't wrong in
saying that Edmond is stupid for
convincing Rhonda the cheese a boxer
dude she didn't even try to level change
or anything she was just standing
upright a hit clinch but [ __ ] was not
working that was like a half a second
eat a shot so giad i don't knows the
gaps but i look at the training videos
like the little [ __ ] bag
and like Edmond going yeah that's right
she and she's pretending yeah just it's
like you don't do that in real you I
don't know which is legit sue and judo
and all that chatter arm yeah this is my
thoughts on it I mean I don't think that
I don't think that she would have won
that fight regardless of whether or not
she was trained by Edmond but I think
that she probably would have lasted
longer than 48 seconds if she got with
somebody who didn't mind [ __ ] her into
believing that she's a boxer and in and
also it's like even if the game plan was
okay eat a shot to close the gap and
then clinch and then you know judo throw
her you can't eat a shot from Amanda
Nunez without getting hurt that girl hit
oh I don't do Mischa said that too
earlier the right hand and you know what
that meant that when she want she was
rushing Edmond like and she had her own
opinion torn she was like dude like why
are you telling this girl to strike with
me yeah you should focus on judo and
what she knows how to do I feel like he
did her dirty but oh yeah that's also a
very a very conscious choice on Rhonda's
part to stay with him so it's not all
his fault that's a very you know that's
50/50 my mom hates her music do you
think that Rhonda is naturally talented
though she doesn't know she's gonna make
the Holly Holm fight Ryan and then
Amanda knew this fight you pasted them
together and then you put it back in
time 10 years ago before people knew who
Ronda was and good this is the the
female face of mm-hmm they'd be like
that chick is awful yeah I mean just her
punching when she went when she fought
Holly and that one thing was she was
rushing and then she
did a little matrix major you know I
mean it's embarrassing
well that's what I'm saying though you
have women like Holly who've competed as
boxers or kick boxers their whole life
and all of a sudden in their 30s they're
like you know what I'm gonna give MMA a
shot and so now they're all coming out
of the woodwork and they've had 20 years
of competition experience and they're
there's a different monster misses
differences what she had it was her time
I okay she loses to holly holm mm-hmm
then you pull a [ __ ] Batman what do
you mean by that's a bad go to you go
yeah you go to a China you pick out of
blue [ __ ] rose you train with Ra's al
Ghul like I'm sure I don't know what I
mean is like you throw it all away
right [ __ ] the movies [ __ ] Hollywood
this is the most important thing in my
life to get this belt back and I'm gonna
do whatever it [ __ ] takes if that
means to lose my house
lose my cars and I am gonna train with
some [ __ ] master sensei I mean that's
the mentality go Michael John I here's
what I think I think with Edmund she's
her evolution as a fighter has
completely been stunted plateaued no I
think that had she been with somebody
who can you know be realistic with her
and say hey you know what you are very
talented in judo and you can destroy
anybody from from this distance oh yeah
but let's be real like you you are not a
natural striker no no if someone could
at least give her that guidance and are
we okay with Ronda Rousey being the
number three or number four fighter
I don't mind she I I'm I'm okay with her
not retiring and just being in
competition let me ask you something I
think she had no warm-up fights you're
gonna like be gone right here yeah
you're just gonna go out for a year then
fight the champ no no no no - no fights
it's like when we saw that
powell-peralta
Bones Brigade documentary yeah what did
you learn out of that a lot of things
but here's what the main and most
important thing to learn in that
documentary Tony Hawk was a prodigy ver
cut he was always being made fun of
right because every street going
straight-laced right and he was
miserable
and rodney mullen had quit doing
competitions a year before oh that's
right right and Tony went to Rodney and
said Rodney mothers with the greatest
street skater yeah he made him have to
trade okay and he said what why are you
so happy because I don't compete anymore
he's free she's he's free yeah and so
Tony would go into competition not
wanting to win but just to have fun yeah
and not needing to be number one
just to be whatever if I take number one
that's cool if I'm fit yeah and then the
pressures lifted and then you can have
fun that's what Rodney's that's exactly
here's my I would love to see Ronda
Rousey continually be a contender in the
top five I don't need and that would
make me respect her and maybe love her
even more to just always be in fighting
contention to just always be in that top
you know top five top you know top ten
even I would do want to continue I did
want to see her fight again yeah but to
her she needs to be one or nothing right
yeah but she's such a big name she's
gonna draw regardless the thing is she
doesn't have to fight anymore she does
need the money but that's not enough you
know that yeah that's like you saying to
you all they did was me you didn't want
you yeah right you'll break your heart
exactly that's what I think that she has
a very very strong competitors heart and
I don't think she can kick it out of her
system that easily okay done I have my
money I don't think money was ever her
driving force especially in the way she
was defeated she was beat the [ __ ] I was
at 4848 face no head movement one of
those hits she didn't know where she was
man and for those of you who are you
guys know that I'm a huge Arsenal FC fan
I love soccer so much and I love that
team and do you know you know what
happened today no do what we play we
play Bournemouth what happened wait no
this is what happened in the first half
we played burn month of course that we
were losing 3-0 to burn man yeah in the
second half we tied it so we got a point
out if we got a point out of it oh but
it was a great point why wait two days
ago
we played Watford right no Crystal
Palace Crystal Palace Crystal Palace my
bad and our guy Olivier Drew who plays
for Arsenal did a kick goal of the year
all the like all of it yeah yeah and
materials doesn't count he was offside
yeah but yeah but Jews goal was so
creative and beautiful you're a soccer
fan at all you have to YouTube Jerusalem
you Google is this
Olivia Jareau scorpion can kick it is
beautiful I mean he was dead yeah yeah
foot did a scorpion there was a man yeah
anyway yeah wonder this Chelsea and
Tottenham played tomorrow yeah okay
so how are you oh here's what I want to
do with you Steve yeah is in your mind
figure out who you want to do a podcast
with yeah you'll be how do we do it but
we'll figure out a way yeah you know
maybe I mean I love all things comedy
yeah maybe but we could it doesn't stop
you from having some independent pilot
recorded they'd be under our umbrella or
no I want to figure that out our net
worth make people make networks so even
with all things comedy we could have our
own network underneath I don't know part
it's a tiger belly product yeah you want
it to be okay we're gonna I want to do
that yeah that's what I want to do I
enjoy this but what's it be able
[Music]